uh matter of fact
listeners know this i uh was the first
boat
on scene when the bridge collapsed in
saint petersburg no you weren't even
around
i didn't i had those guys on the podcast
two of the rescue divers
that pulled all the bodies out i was the
first one there i got newspaper clippers
and me picking up kids and babies
and all the debris you know a bus went
off uh
greyhound bus one yeah yeah it was
crushed i got picked
i even got the newspapers from 40 years
ago
and i actually have that and i'll show
it in one day
i was the first boat coast guard station
cortes
which was out area was on this side of
the sunshine skyway
so we got an alarm goes off and it says
uh
you know a boat hits the bridge that
happened all the time we go pick a
[ __ ] boat start sinking and we help
you know that's what we did the coast
guard
uh uh it was the [ __ ] i think it was
the summit venture
yep it was a summer venture hit the
bridge and i have pictures
of the [ __ ] bridge hanging over the
front of the adventure
and it was a car on the thing dangling
off the edge
well it wasn't dang it was on it like
that it wasn't dangling it wasn't
actually over but there was a piece that
was like facing downward
exactly and i you know
and actually when we got there was
eerily quiet because it was fog
and we look up holy [ __ ] and then you're
seeing debris
and all this and of course everything
but it's cold and we would it took him
30 days to raise
uh no that was the black dorn i don't
know if you know about that
the black dawn was coast guard guys and
one of those guys you know what
guy went to boot camp with so that black
bone was a coast guard buoy tender 180
foot buoy tender
that got hit by the capricorn the
capricorn hits the
the coast guard cutter buoy they
crisscross and the anchor of the
capricorn flips the coast guard boat
and it went down in 90 seconds and 20
20 or 23 or 25 sailors died
really coast guard and they were
entombed in there in the boat
and they couldn't lift them up until
of course their currents and it right
it's very tough i bet the guys on here
were divers i'll tell you
no the guys that were on here were dot
divers so their job was to inspect all
the bridges in florida
ah that's what they did and they were
the first guy they claimed they when
they first got there
there was one boat i think they said it
was a coast guard boat there when they
first got there
and then like eckerd college sent a
bunch of boats out
we actually on uh anna marie island is
where they had a
they set up a command center but the
coast guard ran that whole operation
okay obviously anything in the waterways
the coast guard runs
and we did all the search and rescue and
then the ops and then even when they
were
like doing debris we had a set of
perimeters and all that
for boats and everybody i got great
paper artix i still got them i just
looked at them i have what they call a
disaster album
because i was here for the coast guard
uh uh bridge
uh coast guard cutter black dawn right
matter of fact i was just staying
on a skyway bridge you know at a rest
stop in my rv
and there's a memorial there for the
coast guard cutter blackthorne
really and i didn't see it it was night
time and but i'm gonna go back there and
see it i saw it uh
a sign for it sorry and i do know there
was one did they move that ship after it
sunk or did they leave it oh no
no no no no no they lifted it up they
you know that's a
it's there's a there is a i've dove i'm
a diver too
i dove the black thorn that i think the
boat's out there i think
they might have put it somewhere else
they might have yeah i don't know it's
not under the bridge for sure no no no
no
it's way offshore it's a couple miles
it's like i don't know if they do you
sure it's the blackthorne
i'm almost i'm 90 percent positive that
one up because the blackthorne obviously
it was i don't think it is i'll tell you
why there were people who died
in it they were entombed in it and i
mean they got them out after they wanted
this but they actually suffocated they
didn't drown
there was an airport talking about they
couldn't get oh they got toxic
the air toxicity they died right nowhere
obviously you know uh and i think 13 or
12
sales in the engine room that was sealed
and they could and they actually wrote
stuff on the walls of the black thorn
like you know i love you hon or whatever
it was
and it was kind of sad because we were
picking those guys up and you know when
they came
up and it took 30 days to lift up the
currents and everything are very bad
under that bridge oh yeah and uh you
know you're a diver
i've never dove under the skyway no you
can't and it's not legally allowed
it's a channel number one right uh have
you ever dove uh
down the keys oh yeah all the time do
you ever dive in on the uh
uh not numbers that's fort lauder the
dauntless no i haven't i haven't done
many ships you have to be a master diver
or an advanced diver at least and i was
i was a now
instructor and because the current is so
bad if the
you drop down one side of the ship down
the line
and when you're going down you're
looking like a flag and if you've got
[ __ ] if you let go of that thing you're
going to pick you up five miles away
literally yeah they don't stop anything
they'll pick you up on a sandbar is what
happens
anyway uh there's great diving down
there you know oh yeah then you
and the barracudas oh insane yeah
i did a lot of diving back when i was in
the coast guard especially in hawaii
yeah you know i don't want to [ __ ] zero
that was out there
uh you know then there's what they call
the blow holes and stuff
ever growing up around here especially
we were always like watching
jackass we were big fans like manny
quigg manny pig was always like a
champion commercial free diver
and he would he would enter these big
spear fishing tournaments and win them
and people were he was competing against
scuba divers and he was free diving
wow and uh dude he's a madman he made me
those tridents over there
and now he actually hunts fish with
tridents and he kills boars with
tridents and [ __ ] and gators
crazy stuff [ __ ] psycho the uh so do
you do a lot of diving still
yeah not not as much as i used to but i
do as much as i can i do a lot i mainly
do a lot of free diving not so much
scuba anymore
but but yeah i'm always yeah i haven't
dove since before the before i went away
okay and it's just timing and then
you're supposed to go get re-certified
it's been sold
20 years yeah not that i mean it's not a
big deal
obviously it doesn't take rocket science
to be a diver
uh but you got to know your [ __ ]
especially if you're going to go in
currents and certainly
oh yeah for sure you know we used to do
cave diving where we would take our
tanks off and get through the [ __ ]
caves
i couldn't do it anymore i became
because of prison
i became claustrophobic i'm [ __ ]
severe
claustrophobic now i can see this light
there so i can get out that window
so i'm all right throw the door but i
[ __ ] i mean it's got
it's i couldn't like forget an mri
machine not even [ __ ] close
they got to knock me out i mean
literally anesthesia
yeah i've almost died cave diving uh
free diving through caves in the cayman
islands before i
we just do this thing where we would
dive this ship um
we would free dive this ship in grand
cayman and we would go down
the top of the ship was maybe like 20 10
feet
and then the bottom was like 50 feet wow
that's deep
so we're diving we would free dive and
what we would do we started the bow
and we would work our way through the
ship breathing air pockets i was just
gonna ask you that it had to be air
pockets
we would find little air pockets take a
deep breath and then we would keep going
to find another air pocket
that's pretty crazy that's [ __ ] up man
it was stupid we used to go into caves
in hawaii
and the morai eels oh yeah and their
teeth oh [ __ ] and i said well
but we were fearless man i was a young
kid i was in my 20s man
i didn't give a [ __ ] about anything and
then i i was a bosom mate i don't know
if you know what that is that's like the
guy
runs the ship okay uh i came up oh
captain
you know not a captain like you're full
of a ship
yes but you know those coast guard boats
those 41 foot 44 foot motorboat
i was the captain of those and i used to
go out and rescue people
50 miles out 70 miles we used to have to
do [ __ ] that the kids today didn't have
to we had to
navigate with a sexton if you had a
know-how
we didn't have to [ __ ] hit a button
[ __ ] i mean you know we had lorraine
actually i was in the coast guard when
lorraine a went away and then it was the
lorenz c you don't even know what that
is no i don't have no idea the man it
was if they had these stations all over
would shoot singles and that's all you
picked up
obviously didn't have satellite back
then you know they didn't have all the
communication [ __ ]
right we had actually what they call
dead reckoning you actually like
if there was someone 50 miles out on the
gulf over here yeah
and i've been out 70 miles out there you
know how do you get there
there's no [ __ ] traffic light like i
when i come to your studio today
right go down make a right left on oak
you know oak whatever it is go down you
know gps is telling me everything
yep and back then you know you can't
they'll give you a coordinates
right and they'll give you you know
whatever your latitude and longitude is
and they'll they'll say we're here we're
dead in the water we
need help some the boats sink whatever
it is yeah
and you [ __ ] boom you put it on the
chart and you have the [ __ ] balls of
the wall
out there you don't just get out there
i mean because if you went that direct
line you would end up
10 miles away and never see him because
the currents and the set and drift would
take you wherever
right so you had to do what they called
the
uh navigation you had to set drift and
all this on a chart
and you had to know what you're doing
today these kids hit a button
[ __ ] take me here takes them there
but what if his ghost
i always tell him what happens if that
breaks well we have a backup what if
that breaks now what the [ __ ] you do do
you know how to [ __ ] navigate by the
stars
to get home right i mean you go the
wrong way you're done
i don't give a [ __ ] who you are you're
gonna run out of gas yeah you know i
mean
i don't know maybe it's just that i'm
old maybe i am yeah i've never thought
i've never thought about it i've never
even thought about it no
it's something i'd expect you know i
i've gotten over like i'm so easy going
now
very easygoing unless i've been through
too much of my life
to [ __ ] let things really bother me
you know what i mean it's just
something that doesn't happen anymore
you